deswegen kommen wir gleich zum nächsten
Tagesordnungspunkt da wird es gehen um
die Unterstützung für Studierende und
Fachschüler die Bundesregierung die
wurde ja ziemlich hart kritisiert von
verschiedenster Seite weil im
sogenannten zweiten Entlastungspaket
zunächst keine energiepauschale für
Rentner und Studenten vorgesehen war
dann wurde im dritten Entlastungspaket
eine Einmalzahlung angekündigt für
Rentner sind das 300 Euro da wurde
übrigens sehr entsprechende
Gesetzentwurf letzte Woche auf dem
parlamentarischen Weg gebracht und es
sollen schon diese Woche verabschiedet
werden hier im Bundestag was aus den 200
Euro energiepauschale für Studenten wird
wann das ganze ausgezahlt werden soll da
gibt es doch noch einige Fragen die
Union und die Linke die möchte das hier
zum Thema machen wir hören die erste
Rednerin von der Union Katrin Staffler
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen 45 Tage
45 Tage sind vergangen seit die
Bundesregierung das dritte
Entlastungspaket verkündet hat
45 Tage sei Ziel Frau
Bundesbildungsministerin über die
offensichtlichen Probleme in der
Auszahlung des Zuschusses einfach
schweigen
45 Tage in denen die Bundesregierung
immer noch keine Lösung gefunden hat wie
die 200 Euro auf den Konten der Studis
ankommen sollen
stattdessen hören wir seit 45 Tagen
immer nur Ausreden man ist ja ein
Gespräch mit den Ländern man ist mit den
Gesprächen in den Hochschulen man muss
erst die entsprechenden gesetzlichen
Grundlagen schaffen und so weiter und so
fort ich bin schon gespannt auf die
Ausreden die wir heute hier in dieser
Debatte wieder hören wollen
wahrscheinlich sind die gleichen ich
würde allerdings sagen machen wir uns
doch an der Stelle einfach mal ehrlich
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen hören Sie
auf zu vertuschen dass die
Bundesregierung überhaupt keinen Plan
hat wie sie die 200 Euro Zuschuss
auszahlen
und ehrlicherweise ist es daher auch
überhaupt nicht verwunderlich wenn man
keinen Plan in der Tasche hat wie es
funktionieren soll dann kann man
natürlich auch nicht sagen wann die 200
Euro ausgezahlt werden und trotzdem muss
ich sagen ich bin fast rückwärts über
den vom Stuhl gefallen als ich gehört
habe dass laut internen Zeitplanung in
der Bundesregierung mit einer Auszahlung
im kommenden Jahr erst zu rechnen ist im
kommenden Jahr das kann unmöglich ihr
Ernst sein
der Kollege Kai Gehring
hat in der letzten Wahlperiode an die
ehemalige Bundesbildungsministerin
gesagt ich zitiere sie wäre eine
trödelministerin als es um die
pandemiebedingten Überbrückungshilfen
gegangen ist und später hat er ihr dann
einen ich zitiere wieder
unverantwortliches Krisenmanagement
vorgeworfen der Parlamentarische
Staatssekretär Jens Brandenburg der in
der hat in der Debatte zur sozialen Lage
der Studierenden vor zwei Jahren gesagt
auch da zitiere ich wieder abwarten ist
in der Krise gerade keine Lösung ich
verrate Ihnen was
bei der Überbrückungshilfe in der
corona-pandemie sind zwischen
Ankündigung der Überbrückungshilfe und
den ersten Anträgen die gestellt werden
konnten 40 Tage verlangen für vergangen
40 keine 41 keine 42 keine 43 auch keine
44 schon gleich gar keine 45 es waren 14
seit letzten Freitag also seit dem 14
Oktober geht jeder einzelne Tag an dem
kein einziger Cent bei den Studenten bei
den Studentinnen bei den fachschülern
ankommt auf ihr politisches Konto Frau
Ministerin
so und jetzt fordern wir deswegen als
Union dass das Geld aller spätestens bis
zum 15 November bei denen die es jetzt
so dringend brauchen ankommen muss das
ist das Mindeste was wir tun können und
wenigstens ein klein ein kleines
bisschen zu zeigen dass wir die Nöte
auch dass die Bundesregierung die Nöte
ernst nimmt
und ersparen Sie es uns bitte heute
dass sie sich wieder für die vielen
tollen Maßnahmen abfallt die Sie für die
Studentinnen für die Studenten schon auf
dem Weg gebracht haben wenn man sich das
nämlich mal genauer anschaut dann wird
deutlich dass nichts daran Wumms hat um
mal im Sprachgebrauch der Regierung zu
bleiben Beispiele
Heizkostenzuschuss da haben wir nicht
mal alle Antragsberechtigten den ersten
bekommen was dazu geführt hat dass in
der vorletzten Ausschusssitzung sogar
die Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der SPD
und von den Grünen gefragt haben wie
lang so eine Auszahlung überhaupt dauern
kann FDP verweist auf die Zuständigkeit
der Länder spannend nach neuesten Infos
heute im Ausschuss schaut jetzt zum
Glück mit der Ausnahme von Thüringen ein
bisschen besser aus trotzdem das
Ergebnis ist immer noch unzureichend
zweites Beispiel Bafög Novelle wie kann
man stolz sein auf eine bafög-novelle
die von der Inflation schon aufgefressen
gewesen ist als sie überhaupt in Kraft
getreten ist eigentlich ist es traurig
eigentlich ist es traurig wie einfach
Opposition bei ihnen geht
und liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen es
gibt überhaupt es ist gibt überhaupt
keinen Grund wirklich gar keine
überhaupt keinen Grund diesem Antrag
heute nicht zuzustimmen und zwar ein
sofortabstimmung keine Überweisung an
den Ausschuss keine lange Beratungen
keine Verzögerungstaktik mehr sondern
ein eindeutiges Jahr hier und jetzt die
Studenten da draußen die schauen heute
auf uns sie schauen auf dieses Parlament
in der Hoffnung dass wir Ihnen ein
starkes Signal senden enttäuschen wir
diese nicht danke
sagt Katrin Staffler hier zum Auftakt
der Debatte und in ihrem Antrag der hier
in dieser Debatte zugrunde liegt hat die
Union formuliert dass Studenten und
Fachhochschüler Fachschüler eben schnell
unterstützt werden müssen diese 200 €
ausgezahlt werden müssen so ist es hier
ja auch formuliert worden jetzt hören
wir mal was die SPD dazu sagt Lina
sehr geehrte ZuschauerInnen Zuschauer
wir befinden uns in einer Zeit große
Herausforderungen Vladimir Putin nutzt
Energie als Waffe das Ergebnis sind hohe
Energiepreise die die Inflation nach
oben treiben damit steigt auch das
Armutsrisiko insbesondere für
einkommensschwache Haushalte darunter
natürlich auch viele junge Menschen in
Ausbildung und in diesen Zeiten zeigt
die fortschrittskoalition dass die
handlungsfähig ist wir treffen schnelle
Entscheidungen damit sichergestellt ist
dass die Bürgerinnen und Bürger weiter
heizen können dass die Unternehmen
weiter produzieren dass die
Arbeitsplätze sicher sind erst diese
Woche haben wir die Entscheidung zur
Atomkraft getroffen die Gasspeicher
wurden in den letzten Monaten auf über
95 Prozent gefüllt wir haben wirksame
entlastungspakete für Menschen mit
niedrigen und mittleren Einkommen für
Studierende für Familien für
Rentnerinnen und Rentner auf den Weg
gebracht um die Helen hohen
Lebenshaltungskosten ein Stück weit
auszugleichen mit diesen Maßnahmenbündel
machen wir klar wir lassen euch nicht im
Regen stehen wir unterstützen euch
niemand in Deutschland sollfrieren oder
seine Wohnung verlieren diese Koalition
reagiert mit Augenmaß und Verstand
kraftvoll navigiert Sie dieses Land
durch die Krise
und jetzt komme ich zu ihrem Antrag weil
die Union sich in ihrer oppositionshalle
dagegen weniger kraftvoll wiederfindet
da wird dann auf der einen Seite
kritisiert dass einzelne Gruppen zu
wenig bedacht und insgesamt die Pakete
zu wenig bieten würden und gleichzeitig
wird von sozialtourismus und von
scheinstudierenden gesprochen so als ob
der Sozialstaat massenweise von
Betrügerinnen Betrügern ausgenommen
werden würde liebe Kolleginnen Kollegen
wir sprechen hier von Menschen die sich
in einer existenziellen Krise Leben
nicht von Betrügern
Opposition
Opposition ist wichtig in einer
Demokratie gerade in diesen Zeiten aber
dieses zündeln an den Grundpfeilern
unserer solidarischen Gesellschaft
dieses erzählen von falschen Fakten
gefährdet unseren gesellschaftlichen
Zusammenhalt der heute wichtiger ist
denn je
und darin ein reiht sich auch Ihr Antrag
ein und die Erzählung dass junge
Menschen in Ausbildung von der
Ampelkoalition übersehen werden anders
als sie das in ihrem Antrag Schreiben
kommt die energiepreispauschale nämlich
sehr wohl auch jungen Menschen in
Ausbildung zur gute und zwar den 75
Prozent die neben die Nebenjob haben des
wissen sie auch das haben wir hier
mehrfach bereits geklärt und dieselbe
Gruppe kann von
inflationsausgleichsprämie profitieren
die steuerfrei von den Arbeitgebern
ausgezahlt werden kann dazu kommt der
Heizkostenzuschuss für Bafög beziehen
und es ist eine gute Nachricht dass über
90 Prozent der Länder jetzt den Haus
gehaltskostenzuschuss einst in die
Auszahlung des Heizkostenzuschuss eins
in die Wege geleitet haben und wir
werden ja morgen den Heizkostenzuschuss
zwei noch beschließen der dann ebenfalls
schnell an junge Menschen ausgezahlt
wird auch dazu zählen natürlich die
deutliche Erhöhung des BAföG die
Erhöhung des Mindestlohns wird einmal
Bonus von 100 Euro die für Menschen in
Ausbildung bis zum 26 lebensjahr auch
des neuen euro-tickets
selbstverständlich profitieren junge
Menschen in Ausbildung auch von den
Vorschlägen der gaspreis-kommission und
den Vorhaben der Koalition zur Deckelung
der Energiepreise und jetzt nehmen sie
in ihrem Antrag ja Bezug auf den
Beschluss der Bundesregierung
Studierende sowie Fachschülerinnen und
Fachschüler eine Einmalzahlung in Höhe
von 200 Euro auszuzahlen und ich würde
sagen das ist sehr begrüßenswert dass
sie diesen Vorschlag ebenfalls
unterstützen wir sind glaube ich auch
vereinigt dass die Einmalzahlung
möglichst schnell und unbürokratisch
ausgezahlt werden muss aber und es
wissen sie auch das ist herausfordernd
weil wir haben nun mal keine Datenbank
wo alle Namen alle Schülerinnen und
Schüler aller Studierenden drin sind wo
die Kontodaten drin sind und wir dann
nur noch irgendwo auf den Knopf drücken
müssen und das ganze Geld ist ausbezahlt
das ist nicht so und es wissen sie auch
und hilfreich wäre es von ihrer Seite
doch gewesen wenn sie mal konkrete
Lösungsvorschläge machen gemeinsam mit
den Ländern und der Bundesregierung
einer schnellen Auszahlung zu arbeiten
nicht hilfreich ist dagegen irgendwelche
vermeintlich einzuhaltende
auszahlungsstadlines in den Antrag zu
klatschen das ist das Gegenteil von
seriöser Oppositionspartei dabei das ist
reine Stimmungsmache
ich möchte gerne auch noch was zu dem
Antrag der Linksfraktion sagen den wir
ja hier auch noch beraten der hat
nämlich deutlich mehr Substanz und
greift einige Initiativen unserer
Koalition auf wie zum Beispiel das
bund-länderprogramm junges Wohnen dass
wir von der bundesbauministerin
angekündigt zum ersten ersten 2023
starten wird und auch in der
Strukturreform des BAföG arbeiten wir
mit Hochdruck
liebe Kolleginnen Kollegen sie sehen die
Ampelkoalition lässt junge Menschen in
Ausbildung in dieser herausfordernden
Situation eben nicht im Regen stehen wie
sie es in ihrem Antrag schreiben
stattdessen spannen wir einen breiten
Regenschirm für Sie auf vielen Dank
lina seitzl war das für die SPD ja die
Heizkostenzuschüsse hat sie angesprochen
die 200 Euro die an die Studenten noch
ausgezahlt werden sollen auch gerade an
die die zum Beispiel auch kein Bafög
bekommen da ist die Sache tatsächlich
gar nicht so einfach den anders als
beispielsweise Rentnerinnen und Rentner
erhalten Studierende wenn sie keine
Zuwendung vom Staat bekommen hat man ja
keine Bankverbindung die zentrale
erfasst wird und die sind in Hochschulen
in der Regel ja dann auch nicht bekannt
also da müssen Lösungswege hier auch
zusammen mit den Ländern
über 200 Euro
200 Euro Einmalzahlung für Studenten
wir müssen nur gar nicht so weit
zurückgehen da haben wir hier über ganz
andere Pakete diskutiert 100 Milliarden
für die Rüstungsindustrie 200 Milliarden
letztlich für Energiekonzerne und hier
geht es heute um 200 und Euro da darf
man doch schon mal fragen was kann man
sich von 200 Euro denn eigentlich
leisten was kostet denn die Fahrt zum
Beispiel nach Hause zu den Eltern wenn
man das Ticket voll bezahlen muss im ICE
was kostet denn inzwischen eine
Tankfüllung ich hoffe von Ihnen wissen
das noch die meisten es gibt ja einige
Minister oder Kanzler sogar die nicht
mehr wissen was der Sprit an der
Tankstelle so derzeit kostet
ja und ich merke schon an ihrer Unruhe
dass das genau der wunde Punkt ist
nämlich das können sich viele Studenten
heutzutage gar nicht mehr leisten meine
Damen und Herren
und wenn ich mir dann angucke
Entschuldigung Frau Kollegin Salze sind
zwar gerade mit ihrem Handy beschäftigt
aber es geht ja auch hier um ihre
Politik und Sie müssen doch schon
zugeben sie haben das gerade so
dargestellt als hätte das alles sinn und
verstand was sie gemacht haben aber wenn
wir uns die vielen einzelgesetze
anschauen dann erkennt man doch in der
Gesamtschau nicht irgendwie ein
sinnvolles planvolles Vorgehen sondern
das einzige was ich hier erkenne was
meine Fraktion hier erkennt ist eine
heillose Flickschusterei der eine Fehler
den sie gemacht haben war ja dass Sie
dass Sie hier ein Teil der Studenten
vergessen haben ja sie haben an die
gedacht die das BAföG haben aber haben
dann gesehen wo es gibt ja noch andere
die beziehen kein Bafög so dann gibt es
jetzt die Einmalzahlung für andere auch
wieder mit der Gießkanne
sie kriegen das natürlich in der Kürze
der Zeit nicht hin zu differenzieren das
heißt diese 200 Euro wer bekommt die
denn bekommen dass die wirklich
Bedürftigen vielleicht auch aber es
bekommen auch die die es gar nicht
brauchen also auch hier ist kein System
und kein Verstand dabei vielleicht auch
noch ein Wort zu den beiden vorliegenden
Anträgen liebe Frau Staffler leider muss
ich sagen ist ja schon richtig dass es
alles schneller geschehen müsste und
ihre Kritik ist ja auch geht ja in die
richtige Richtung andererseits drücken
aber auch sie sicher darum herum die
eigentlichen Probleme anzusprechen denn
warum haben denn viele Studenten und
übrigens nicht nur die Studenten sondern
viele Auszubildende überhaupt alle
Menschen derzeit ein Problem diese
Probleme sind ja nicht vom Himmel
gefallen sondern die Probleme haben auch
zu tun mit der Sanktionspolitik die sich
und das wird immer offenbarer meine
Damen und Herren inzwischen gegen unsere
eigenen Bürger richtet
[Applaus]
deshalb wäre das der erste Vorschlag der
sich nicht auf Symptom Behandlung
bezieht sondern an die Ursachen
herangeht hören sie auf mit der
Sanktionspolitik sorgen Sie dafür dass
wieder ausreichend Energie auf der
Angebotsseite zur Verfügung steht dann
kriegen wir auch die Inflation in den
Griff und nur dann wenn wir die
Inflation in den Griff kriegen können
wir dieses Problem wirklich dauerhaft
lösen denn was wollen Sie denn machen
diese eine Einmalzahlung wird doch nicht
reichen kommt dann die nächste
Einmalzahlung vielleicht von 250 Euro
dann wieder 235 Euro wie weit soll das
denn noch gehen wir vermissen hier
Vorschläge die wirklich das Problem an
der Wurzel packen und dazu gehören auch
noch ganz andere Bereiche die ja zum
Glück jetzt sichtbar werden nämlich dass
ihre Energiewende die nicht sie allein
sondern auch die
Vorgängerregierung hier vorangetrieben
hat dass auch diese Energiewende ja mit
daran schuld ist dass die Probleme in
denen wir jetzt gemeinsam stecken
überhaupt so groß sind wie sie sind
deshalb unser zweiter Tipp für Sie um
wirklich an die Ursachen heranzugehen
nehmen Sie Abstand von ihrer verkorksten
Energiewende kommen Sie zurück zu einem
vernünftigen Energie-Mix dann geht es
auch mit unserer Wirtschaft wieder voran
denn nur mit einer funktionierenden
Wirtschaft kann letztlich auch Geld
generiert werden eingenommen werden dass
sie schließlich brauchen um es dann zu
verteilen vielen Dank meine Damen und
Herren
[Applaus]
kurzfremmingen war das für die
afd-fraktion am Rednerpult jetzt für die
Fraktion Bündnis 90 Grünen die
Abgeordnete Laura Kraft
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Frau Ministerin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen liebe Zuschauer
auf den Tribünen so jetzt kommen wir mal
zum Antrag der Union also der lässt
ehrlich gesagt einfach nur zu wünschen
übrig denn das fängt schon damit an dass
sie behaupten dass nur 4% aller
Studierenden in Deutschland von dem
Heizkostenzuschuss profitiert hätten und
dann verweisen Sie auch auf eine
bundestags-rucksache so damit da ist ja
schon mal der erste Fehler denn sie
haben ja in der Fragestunde am 28
September danach gefragt an wie viele
Studierende ist der Heizkostenzuschuss
schon ausgezahlt worden und da hat ihn
der Parlamentarische Staatssekretär
Mario Brandenburg erklärt und das war
dann der Stand vom 23 September das von
300.000 ungefähr 300.000
Anspruchsberechtigten schon 122.2
73 das ausbezahlt bekommen haben so es
sind nämlich nur die
bafög-empfängerinnen anspruchsberechtigt
gewesen und nicht alle Studierenden also
ihre rumrechnerei die ist da völlig
Fakten befreit ist gegen den ich nicht
ja also da sind wir nicht bei 4 Prozent
da muss man einfach mal wissen wovon man
redet also das ist ja nur ein Punkt in
ihrem Antrag sie behaupten nein sie
behaupten ja da einfach dass die
Ampelkoalition die Studierenden völlig
vergessen hätte also das ist nein das
ist nachweislich falsch ich kann ihn mal
auflisten was wir alles bereits gemacht
haben oder im Inbegriff sind zu tun das
ist so viel dass ich das Aufschreiben
musste so Erhöhung der bafög-sätze und
Ausweitung der bafög-berechtigung
nothilfe-mechanismus Kindergelderhöhung
zwei zwei Heizkostenzuschüsse den einen
denen sie da eben schon falsch sprechen
haben plus der der jetzt dann morgen
kommt die Anhebung der
minijobsverdienstgrenze energiepauschale
für werbstätige
wohngeldreform 9 Euro Ticket wovon ja
auch Studierende profitiert haben und
dann auch noch mal die Einmalzahlung so
das ist aber nur ein Auszug des Ganzen
und Sie haben ja heute dann letzten
Endes dann auch im Ausschuss erfahren
was ist der Stand der Auszahlung hat
ihnen dann auch der Parlamentarische
Staatssekretär Jens Brandenburg erklärt
das schon 15 von 16 Ländern im
auszahlungsprozess sind bzw den auch
teilweise schon abgeschlossen haben also
da sind sie jetzt eigentlich auch völlig
auf dem Holzweg und ihr gesamter Antrag
da muss man ja ehrlich sagen so da haben
sie vier Forderungen von diesen vier
Forderungen also da wollen sie einmal
dass sie das ist unbürokratisch bis
allerspätestens 15 November ausgezahlt
wird dann wollen sie einen
unbürokratisches antrags- und
Bewilligungsverfahren digital
niedrigschwellige Nachweispflicht aber
auch Kontrollen so nee aber ich werde
sie merken dass da Zielkonflikte Sinn
und das Ganze bis zu 15 November sie
wissen ja dass die Bundesregierung auch
mit den Ländern im Gespräch ist und
natürlich auch versucht das ist nämlich
nicht banal das irgendwie auf dem Weg zu
bringen sie sehen da haben sie schon
mehrere Aspekte
nehmen Sie sich doch einfach mal ein
Beispiel an der Antrag der Linken der
macht nämlich wirklich konstruktive
Vorschläge sie schlagen ja überhaupt
nichts vor Frau Kollegin ja also ich
glaube das Lob der Linken muss leider
wegfallen sie können keine besseren
Anträge stellen aber ich weiß auch
stimmt oder sie haben sich keine Mühe
gegeben und das ist einfach
[Musik]
unverfield aber Kraft von den Grünen
Look hier schon mal den Antrag der
Linken dazu haben wir noch nicht allzu
viel gehört dass wird jetzt aber
nachgeholt ganz sicher von Nicole
nämlich die jetzt für die Linke spricht
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ja hier kommt
sie die konstruktiv Opposition ne es
waren also die Inflation und die krasse
Teuerungswelle machen auch vor den
Studierenden und vor den Schülerinnen
und Schülern nicht halt auch sie haben
Angst vor der Zukunft haben Angst um die
eigene Existenz und haben natürlich auch
Sorge wie sie unter diesen Bedingungen
eigentlich ihr Studium oder die
Ausbildung schaffen sollen jetzt hat
sich die Bundesregierung richtigerweise
dazu durchgerungen auch die Studierenden
bei den Entlastungen mitzudenken bislang
war es ja so dass von den Zahlungen
immer nur ein Teil der Studis profitiert
hat den ersten und zweiten
Heizkostenzuschuss konnten nur die
bekommen die Bafög beziehen also nur 11
Prozent der Studis und Studierenden die
energiepauschale wiederum haben nur die
Erwerbstätigen Studierenden bekommen
können und jetzt sollen eben alle
Studierenden und die Fachschülerinnen
und Fachschüler eine Einmalzahlung in
Höhe von 200 Euro erhalten das ist jetzt
zwar noch nicht so dass die damit über
den Winter kommen und die steigenden
Lebensmittel Energiepreise wirklich
decken können aber es ist ein Schritt in
die richtige Richtung wenn es nicht
einen Haken gäbe bislang ist nämlich
wirklich völlig unklar wie und wann das
Geld bei Ihnen ankommt und Frau Kraft da
muss ich auch sagen heute im Ausschuss
hat natürlich der Parlamentarische
Staatssekretär über den Stand der
Auszahlungen beim Heizkostenzuschuss 1
gesprochen und nicht über die 200 Euro
und ich muss mich schon auch anschließen
und sagen Kolleginnen und Kollegen von
der Ampel stellen sie endlich sicher
dass die Hilfen ankommen das Geld wird
dringend gebraucht
und und das ist höchste Zeit auch noch
ein paar andere Ideen für Hilfsmaßnahmen
für Menschen in Ausbildung auf den Weg
zu bringen zum Beispiel der ÖPNV müsste
für Schülerinnen und Schüler für
Auszubildenden und Studierende endlich
kostenfrei sein das wäre doch meine
zielgerichtete Unterstützung und es muss
sich endlich was tun beim studentischen
Wohnraum die Wohnheimplätze der
Studentenwerke reichen hinten und vorne
nicht aus starten Sie jetzt endlich
durch mit ihrem angekündigten Programm
für junges Wohnen und für Auszubildende
auch das kann ich warten die Menschen
haben jetzt die Nöte warum dauert das
eigentlich immer alles so lange und es
ist höchste die strukturellen Probleme
anzugehen die den Studierenden das Leben
schwer machen nämlich die Tatsache dass
jede und jeder dritte Studierende und
zwar schon vor Inflation und
Energiekrise dass jede und jeder dritte
Studierende von Armut betroffen ist und
das eben nur 11 Prozent der Studis Bafög
beziehen das ist doch auch das Problem
was die jetzige Situation so verschärft
und was eben auch dazu führt dass auch
die Einmalzahlungen wenn sie denn dann
endlich mal ankommen nur ein Tropfen auf
den heißen Stein sind weil sie eben die
strukturelle Armut in der ein Teil der
Studierenden lebt nicht auffangen können
und deswegen nochmal es muss jetzt um
eine bafögreform gehen die ein Studium
die eine Existenz tatsächlich absichert
ein Bafög von dem man die Miete und den
Internetanschluss sicher bestreiten kann
und dass ich automatisch an die
Inflation anpasst und diese Entwicklung
nicht immer hinterher hängt und ein BAF
und ein Bafög dass die Tür für mehr
BezieherInnen und beziehe nicht nur den
kleinen Spalt aufmacht sondern die Tore
weit aufmacht und dann Kolleginnen und
Kollegen von der Ampel dann könnte man
auch mal wirklich von einem Wumms reden
um in der Rhetorik der Ampel zu bleiben
denn bisher ist das was sie machen finde
ich nicht so sehr Wumms sondern ein
bisschen mehr Puff ich bitte Sie um
Zustimmung zu unserem Antrag vielen Dank
ja und den hat Nicole Gohlke hier noch
mal mit einem mit einigen Einzelheiten
vorgestellt jetzt hören wir für die
FDP-Fraktion Reha Schröder sie ist die
bildungspolitische Sprecherin der
Liberalen
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen die
Bildungsministerin hat sich erfolgreich
für die Unterstützung von Studierenden
sowie Fachschülerinnen und fachschülern
eingesetzt 200 Euro bekommt jede und
jeder Einzelne angesichts der hohen
Energiekosten ist das eine richtige und
notwendige Entlastung für junge Menschen
das bmdf hat letzte Woche im Ausschuss
bereits berichtet dass das Haus in enger
Abstimmung mit den Ländern schnell eine
Rechtsgrundlage und einen
unbürokratisches Verfahren zur
Auszahlung schafft und das ist gar nicht
trivial ich habe mich deswegen wirklich
gefreut auf die Anträge der Opposition
sie als Union haben da ja auch viel
Erfahrung im Haus und war wirklich ganz
gespannt auf Ihre Vorschläge für die
Auszahlungsmodalitäten leider wurde ich
enttäuscht und dann lese ich im Antrag
der Union auch noch von
Nachweispflichten um Schein Studierende
auszusortieren was ist das eigentlich
scheinstudierende damit zeigen Sie
leider einmal mehr ihren Argwohn und ihr
Misstrauen gegenüber jungen Menschen in
diesem Land auch deshalb werden wir
Ihren Antrag ablehnen
meine Damen und Herren die
Bundesregierung die lässt junge Menschen
eben gerade nicht im Regen stehen wir
entlasten Sie ganz konkret und ich
verstehe auch dass es manchmal schwierig
ist den Überblick zu behalten und wenn
euch das auch so geht dann aufgepasst
denn für Euch kommt jetzt eine
Zusammenfassung in zehn Punkten erstens
wenn ihr im letzten Winter Bafög
bekommen habt oder aufstiegs-bafög dann
bekommt ihr den Heizkostenzuschuss 1 230
Euro in Hamburg wurde der etwa Ende
September ausbezahlt ganz unbürokratisch
und für diesen Winter entlasten wir euch
sogar nochmal mit einem
Heizkostenzuschuss 2 in Höhe von 345
Euro checkt mal ob der Zuschuss schon
angekommen ist bei vielen ist das der
Fall zweitens dank der bafög-novelle zu
diesem Wintersemester erhalten mehr
Menschen mehr Bafög auch wenn ihr das im
ersten Semester nicht bekommen habt
vielleicht auch nicht mehr im ersten
Semester seid dann ist das jetzt eine
gute Gelegenheit den Anspruch noch mal
zu prüfen beim Online bafög-rechner da
kann man das ganz bürokratisch tun und
bekommt eine erste Einschätzung das
BAföG ist eine gute Sache nutzt das
dritter Punkt
drittens wir haben zum ersten Oktober
die minijob-trends erhöht auf 520 Euro
und den Mini und den Mindestlohn auf 12
Euro wenn ihr neben dem Studium also
jobbt dann könnt ihr jetzt mehr dazu
verdienen mein Tipp ist übrigens auch
rechnet euren Stundenlohn mal aus schaut
sprecht mit eurem Arbeitgeber ob ihr
wirklich auch die die entsprechende
Erhöhung bekommt damit die 520 Euro auch
wirklich ankommen vierter Punkt im
Gegensatz zur Behauptung der Union habt
ihr mit eurem Nebenjob ebenfalls im
September die energiepreispauschale in
Höhe von 300 Euro bekommen ganz
automatisch über die Lohnabrechnung
fünfter Punkt das 9 euro-ticket das
haben viele junge Menschen gefeiert
zurecht mit dem digitalen
unbürokratischen wissing-ticket wird
Mobilität dauerhaft und einfach günstig
sechster Punkt das Kindergeld das
Kindergeld wird erhöht und eure Eltern
erhalten zum ersten Januar 2318 Euro
mehr im Monat also insgesamt 237 Euro
außerdem augen auf bei der Strom- und
Gasrechnung denn die siebte Maßnahme die
kommt im Frühjahr im nächsten Jahr mit
der gaspreisbremse und die
dezemberrechnung für eure WG oder eure
Wohnung die geht auf Christian Lindners
Nacken eigentlich auf die des
Bundeshaushalt aber ihr wisst was
gemeint ist 8 Punkt durch den Wegfall
der EEG-Umlage spart ihr schon seit dem
ersten siebten 3,72 Cent pro
Kilowattstunde um sich das mal ein
bisschen vorzustellen für eine Vierer WG
sind das ungefähr 300 Euro im Jahr das
ist glaube ich eine ganz gute Sache und
der Stromanbieter der kann das auch
nicht einbehalten sondern der muss diese
Einsparung weitergeben letzter letzte
zwei Punkte 9 und 10 die
umsatzsteuersenkung auf 7% für Gas die
verschobene co2-preiserhöhung all diese
Entlastung meine Damen und Herren die
kommen automatisch bei den jungen
Menschen an und das macht Energie in
dieser angespannten Lage günstiger
so ich glaube das zeigt deutlich die die
Bundesregierung entlastet junge Menschen
ganz massiv eine Sache das weiß ich aus
vielen Gesprächen und Nachrichten von
jungen Menschen die ist denen aber noch
wichtiger als die finanzielle
Unterstützung die wollen nämlich endlich
zur Schule gehen in die Unis gehen wie
das eigentlich gedacht ist die wollen
lernen die wollen mit inhaltlichen
Debatten in den Klassenzimmern in den
Vorlesungen in den Tutorien miteinander
streiten die wollen gemeinsam lernen den
Bibliotheken neue fachliche und
menschliche Erfahrungen sammeln das muss
wieder möglich sein und deswegen müssen
Schulen und Hochschulen offen bleiben
das ist ein Appell an die Universitäten
auch an die Länder und das ist deswegen
auch etwas was wir gemeinsam schaffen
müssen denn in den Ländern sind manchmal
die die Oppositionen hier sind in der
Regierung ich freue mich deswegen wenn
wir im Bildungsbereich alle an einem
Strang ziehen für die jungen Menschen in
unserem Land
so das war der kleine Serviceteil auch
hier von Seiten der FDP von Ria Schröder
man kann das übrigens auch
zu großen Teil Nachlesen auf
www.bundesregierung.de Entlastung für
Studierende da ist es im einzelnen auch
noch mal aufgelistet Gitter konnte man
für die Union kommen wir doch mal vom
YouTube-Kanal den die Kollegin Schröder
gerade bedient hat zurück zum Plenum
denn ehrlicherweise sollten wir
miteinander sprechen und ich
übereinander und ich glaube dass eine
ernsthaft geführte Debatte ohne Polemik
tatsächlich mehr den Interessen der
Betroffenen gerecht wird denn
ehrlicherweise am Ende des Geldes ist
noch viel Monat übrig der Spruch ist
nicht neu schon vor der Krise war das
Thema Geld für viele Studenten und
Fachschüler tatsächlich
existenziell denn wir wissen sie fahren
mit ihren monatlichen Budgets immer
knapp auf Kante und deshalb schlägt die
Inflation doch bei ihnen besonders
gnadenlos zu das begann mit dem Preisen
für Lebensmittel jetzt Energie für
Wohnung die gehen wirklich auf dem
Zahnfleisch und zwar seit Monaten und
wer jetzt gerade oh sagt und diese
Einwürfe sind ja in dem Protokoll zu
leben der zeigt dass sie es nicht ernst
nehmen
das ist diese Polemik die die Menschen
umtreibt und der frei und am Ende
Politik das Vertrauen entzieht sagen wir
doch wo wir uns einig sind wir sind uns
einig dass Studenten und Fachschüler
Hilfe brauchen und zwar so schnell wie
möglich denn bislang wurden Studenten
und Fachschüler vergessen beim ersten
Entlastungspaket beim zweiten
Entlastungspaket in dem Füllhorn war für
sie nichts dabei und da habe ich
manchmal den Eindruck sie brauchen jetzt
auch nicht zu zetern beruhigen sie sich
sondern kommen sie aus ihrem
Paralleluniversum zurück in diese Welt
und in dieser Welt ist es so dass bei
der Energiepreis geldpauschale Studenten
und Fachschüler vergessen wurden sofern
sie kein Nebenjob hatten die anderen
sind leer ausgegangen und der
Heizkostenzuschuss 1 und ich würde
empfehlen bei Ausschusssitzung entweder
oder wie auch immer dabei zu sein dann
hätten sie in der letzten Woche gehört
dass ihr Staatssekretär Jens
Brandenburger gesagt hat dass es bei
sechs Prozent bislang erst angekommen
ist sie haben die bafög-debatte ins Feld
geführt aber seien Sie doch einmal
ehrlich ihre sogenannte
jahrhundert-reform hat eine
Halbwertszeit von Radon schnell
zerfallend das zeigt sich am sogenannten
notfallmechanismus mit Tamtam eingeführt
hilft aber jetzt keinen Betroffenen und
das haben sie selbst erkannt deshalb
jetzt beim Entlastungspaket drei eine
Einmalzahlung angekündigt das war am 4
September 2022 Kollegin Staffler hat
darauf hingewiegen seit 45 Tagen warten
Studenten und Fachschülerinnen wenn man
nicht weiß wie man Essen bezahlen soll
zählen nämlich Tage die Aussicht auf 200
Euro sind sicherlich nicht der große
Wurf aber 200 Euro würden eine kleine
knaufpause geben deshalb haben sich
Schüler und Studenten und Fachschüler
über das Versprechen der Regierung sehr
gefreut aber versprechen muss man
einlösen und deshalb fragen wir sie
jetzt alle in der Ampel wann kommt das
Geld auf dem Konto an nicht wann haben
Sie es in der Dienst die Antwort bleibt
die Regierung schuldig seit Wochen wir
haben in unterschiedlichen Gremien
gefragt wann wird das Geld ausgezahlt
wie die Antwort des BMBF man sucht nach
einer Lösung seit Wochen dafür wurde ein
Arbeitskreis eingesetzt liebe Frau
Ministerin stark Watzinger sie hätten
jetzt die Möglichkeit oder die Ampel
sich hier zu erklären welches Gesetz
wollen sie ändern wer soll die
auszahlende Stelle sein weshalb sollen
alle Studenten 200 Euro bekommen warum
machen sie es nicht bedarfsgerecht wieso
haben sie Meisterschüler ausgespart und
geht man so mit den Fachkräften von
morgen um
fragen über Fragen und keine Antworten
dieser Bundesregierung von Taten ganz zu
schweigen Leidtragenden sind Studierende
und Fachschüler ohne Frage und das ist
eine berechtigte Frage die Auszahlung
ist eine organisatorische
Herausforderung aber es geht wir standen
in der großen Koalition und die SPD möge
sich erinnern 2020 beider
Überbrückungshilfe für Studierende
ebenfalls unter enormen Druck
Studierende in pandemiebedingten
Notlagen konnten damals bis zu 500 Euro
beantragen
zuständig waren die regionalen
Studentenwerke es wurden seitens der
damaligen Bundesministerin Anja
Karliczek eine bundesweit einheitliche
IT-Plattform eingerichtet online
gestellt abgewickelt über die
Studentenwerke die
zusageankündigung erfolgte am 30 April
2020 40 Tage später konnte man die
Anträge stellen der Kollege Gehring hat
damals gesagt das sei trödeln wenn dies
Ihr Maßstab ist dann kann ich Ihnen nur
sagen wenn 45 Tage damals für Sie
trödeln war befindet sich ihre
Ministerin seit Wochen im vorgezogenen
Winterschlaf Kollegin vor diesem
Hintergrund werden sie Frau Kollegin sie
kommen zum Ende bitte jetzt lösen sie
ihr Versprechen ein bringt sie das Geld
zur Auszahlung vielen Dank
gesagt Gitta Connemann von der CDU
CSU-Fraktion
auch in Richtung natürlich der
zuständigen Ministerin Bettina stark
Watzinger die Bundesbildungsministerin
die hier auf der Regierungsbank dieser
Aussprache zuhört
Jens Pike für die SPD
sehr Präsidentin sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren Abgeordnete im Antrag der CDU der
ist überschrieben mit den Worten wir
sollen Studierende Fachschule und
Fachschüler in der Krise unterstützen
das ist völlig richtig und völlig
unstrittig und es gibt hier niemanden
der das anders sieht
einig in unserem Land darf es nicht sein
dass sie Studierende Fachschule und
Fachschüler zwischen warmer Wohnung oder
war Mittagessen entscheiden müssen
deshalb haben wir und deshalb haben wir
schon mehrfach gehört zwei
Heizkostenzuschüsse einmal 230 einmal
345 Euro geschlossen deshalb haben wir
mit der bafög-reform unter anderem ein
nothilfe-mechanismus geschaffen der
greift für nichts anderes mehr hilft und
weil es als Unterstützung nicht nur der
Krise braucht hat die Koalition in Bafög
Höchstsatz auf 934 Euro erhöht und wer
neben dem Studium arbeitet
was fast zwei Drittel der Studierenden
tun hat
die energiepreispauschale von 300 Euro
erhalten ebenso wie die meisten
Studentinnen und Studenten die Arbeiten
auch von der mindestlohnerhöhung von 12
Euro profitieren und jetzt im dritten
Entlastungspaket haben wir ausdrücklich
Studierende Fachschule und Fachschule
aufgenommen mit einer Einmalzahlung in
Höhe von 200 Euro und wenn Sie jetzt
hier behaupten die Bundesregierung
unterstütze studentenforschung
Fachschüler nicht lasst sie im Regen
stehen wie es bei ihm Antrag heißt dann
geht es ihnen weder um die Studierenden
hat man das Gefühl oder eine Fachschule
Fachschüler sondern sie verunsichern
hier die Menschen die es geht um Frau
ponnemann das entzieht der Politik
vertrauen
sie unterstellen hier
wir würden einzelne Gruppen vergessen
werden und sie versuchen politischen
profitas die Situation zu schlagen das
wird ihrer staatspolitischen
Verantwortung glaube ich in dieser Lage
nicht gerecht
die Bundesregierung unterstützt und
entlastet und hilft an ganz vielen
Stellen mit allen zur Verfügung
stehenden Mitteln in der Breite der
Bevölkerung mit der Erhöhung des
Kindergeldes mit dem Wegfall der
EEG-Umlage mit einer Senkung der
Umsatzsteuer auf Gas der Ausweitung des
wohngelds oder mit dem neuen euro-ticket
alles zusätzliche Maßnahmen die in der
Breite der Bevölkerung wirken und auch
bei Studierenden Fachschülerinnen und
fachschülern denn für uns als Koalition
ist eins ganz klar
wir müssen und wir werden diese
Gesellschaft zusammenhalten niemanden in
diesem Land muss Sorge haben hinten
runter zu fallen
und sie kommen mit ihrer Forderung zu
spät und dann bleibt nicht mehr in ihrem
Antrag als zu sagen das was die
Regierung macht es gut aber sie müsste
es mal ein bisschen schneller tun ja
natürlich sind wir mit alle Maßnahmen so
schnell wie möglich umzusetzen sie
fordern eine zügige Auszahlung der 200
Euro je früher desto besser heißt es da
und sie unterstellen damit das würden
wir nicht tun
aber ich meine auch da ist wieder auch
schon öfter in diesem Haus gesagt aber
notwendig vielleicht mal an andere
Aussagen von ihnen vor sechs Monaten zu
erinnern noch im März haben sie im
gasendbare gefordert dass uns
unvorbereitende Wirtschaftskrise
katapultierte da haben wir bereits das
erste Entlastungspaket auf dem Weg
gebracht
und im Sommer waren sie damit
beschäftigt massive Unterstützung mit
Waffen für Ukraine zu fordern haben wir
das zweite Entlastungspaket beschlossen
und jetzt haben wir das dritte
Entlastungspaket beschlossen und ein
Abwehrschirm gegensteigende Preise und
für mit dem Bürgergeld ein Sozialsystem
hat dass die Menschen wieder Vertrauen
fassen können und ich sage das so
deutlich weil was machen sie das gehört
auch zu Debatte sie spielen beim
Bürgergeld geringen verdiene gegen
Leistungsbezieher aus bei den
Entlastungen Rentner gegen
Erwerbstätigen und jetzt Fachschulen und
Fachschüler Studierende gegen den Rest
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen der CDU
ich habe das Gefühl sie versuchen immer
weiter zu spalten und das bereitet mir
Sorge sagt das ganz deutlich und
deswegen sage ich hier wir als
ampelkonditionen stehen für
gesellschaftlichen Zusammenhalt und eins
eint uns in dieser Koalition dass wir
das Land fortschrittlich und
sozialgerechter machen wollen auch und
gerade in dieser Krise
und uns allen dass wir dafür
Verantwortung übernehmen
Verantwortung damit niemand frieren muss
weil es genug Gas gibt und das auch
bezahlbar ist für alle das verlangt uns
natürlich einiges ab und das ist nicht
immer einfach bei der Frage wie
russisches Gas jetzt Energieträger
setzen wie mit Waffenlieferung
Krisengebiete umgehen oder auch wie was
das mit dem Haushalt macht aber alle
drei Regierungsverantwortung tun eins
ohne Wind aber sie übernehmen diese
Verantwortung und wir werden dieses Land
durch diese Krise tragen und das so
schnell natürlich wie es geht mit allen
Maßnahmen die ich gerade genannt habe
auch wenn staatsverantwortung auch
bedeutet es ordentlich durchzuführen den
Haushalt im Blick zu haben und es
verordnet auf dem Weg zu bringen
herzlichen Dank
Jens Kalk war das für die SPD-Fraktion
und als letzte Rednerin hier zu diesem
Tagesordnungspunkt hören wir jetzt die
Abgeordnete Marlene Schöneberger für die
Fraktion Bündnis 90 grünen sitzt im
Ausschuss für Bildung und Forschung
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Frau Ministerin liebe
Kolleginnen der demokratischen
Fraktionen
ja eine Promotion abschließt hängt in
Deutschland noch immer massiv von den
finanziellen Möglichkeiten und dem
Bildungsweg der Eltern ab etwa 30
Prozent der Kinder aus nicht
akademischen Haushalten studieren bei
Akademiker in den Eltern sind es fast
dreimal so viele das nicht jeder Mensch
frei entscheiden kann wie Zukunft
aussehen soll weil diese Menschen an
finanzielle Grenzen stoßen das ist
ungerecht und undemokratisch und dagegen
kämpfen wir als Ampelkoalition mit allen
Mitteln
die Ungerechtigkeiten im Bildungsbereich
haben sich während der Pandemie noch
verstärkt in der Schule wurden gerade
die schüler:innen die es zuvor schon
schwer hatten weiter abgehängt und ein
Unis sieht es ähnlich aus ich brauche
nicht auszuführen zu welchen Krisen es
in der Pandemie geführt hat wenn der
Minijob weg und die Mensa geschlossen
war schon vor der Pandemie war ein
Drittel der Studierenden in Deutschland
von Armut betroffen das ist doppelt so
hoch wie in der Gesamtbevölkerung
gleichzeitig ist der Anteil der
bafög-bezieherinnen in den letzten
Jahren massiv gesunken die Förderung hat
längst nicht mehr alle erreicht die auf
sie angewiesen waren liebe Kolleginnen
von der Unionsfraktion ist es dann
vielsagender Zeitpunkt indem sie ihr
Herz für Studierende entdecken jetzt wo
sie in der Opposition sind sie hatten 16
Jahre Zeit im Bildungsministerium danke
dass Sie das Stichwort trödelministerin
noch mal genannt haben die prekäre
Situation vieler Studierender geht zu
großen Teilen auf Ihr Konto
diese Einmalzahlungen über die wir heute
sprechen ist natürlich nur ein Pflaster
in einer sozialen Notlage ist reicht
nicht wir sind seit fast einem Jahr
dabei die finanzielle Situation von
jungen Menschen langfristig zu
verbessern es wurde schon viel genannt
aber weil ich nach der letzten
unionsrede davon überzeugt bin dass es
immer noch nicht bei allen angekommen
ist wir sind gerade mitten in einer
bafög-reform wir haben bereits die
Fördersätze deutlich erhöht Menschen
können länger und Eltern unabhängiger
beantragen im Entlastungspaket 3 haben
wir endlich eine wichtige Lücke
geschlossen wir haben das Kindergeld
angehoben und Studierende auch
ausländische mit einbezogen nach den
Entlastungen für betriebliche
ausbildende und Minijob erinnern werden
nur noch schüler:innen und
Auszubildenden Fachschulen profitieren
und auch das neun oder 49 euro-ticket
und erhöhte Mindestlohn die werden ganz
besonders jungen Menschen zugute kommen
mit uns bleibt niemand allein
ich finde es gut ich finde es gut dass
wir heute über die Situation junger
Menschen sprechen auch wenn ich nach
dieser Debatte bezweifle dass es allen
hier wirklich um junge Menschen geht
aber es stimmt es ist wichtig dass wir
die 200 Euro so schnell wie möglich
auszahlen wir werden niemanden vergessen
wir werden bürokratische Hürden
vermeiden aber das geht nicht von heute
auf morgen und alle die schon mal
regiert haben müssen das eigentlich auch
wissen
wir sind immer offen für konstruktive
Vorschläge und dieses Verfahren zu
beschleunigen aber dazu habe ich von
Ihnen heute nichts gehört und deswegen
lehnen wir Ihren Antrag ab vielen Dank
Schönenberger letzte Rednerin jetzt
hören wir mal die
Bundestagsvizepräsidentin
so in der cdu/csu auf Drucksache 40-44
mit dem Titel Studierende sowie
Fachschülerinnen und Fachschüler jetzt
in der Krise unterstützen 200 Euro
Zuschuss zügig auszahlen wer stimmt
dafür
wer stimmt dagegen
wer enthält sich bei Enthaltung der
Fraktion DIE LINKE Zustimmung durch
cdu/csu und AFD gegen gestimmt haben die
koalitionsfraktion ist der Antrag
abgelehnt jetzt komme ich zum an zur
Abstimmung mit den Antrag der Fraktion
Die Linke auf Drucksache 4052 mit dem
Titel Unterstützung für Studierende und
Fachschülerinnen und Fachschüler
krisenfest gestalten nicht nur in diesem
Winter wer stimmt dafür
wer stimmt dagegen
fair enthält sich damit ist der Antrag
abgelehnt zugestimmt hat die
einbringende Fraktion alle anderen haben
den Antrag abgelehnt ich rufe jetzt auch
wieder die beiden Anträge von der Union
von der Linken die haben hier keine
Mehrheit gefunden das hatte sich ja auch
schon angedeutet in der Debatte die
Ampelkoalition hat es hier mit ihrer
Mehrheit abgewendet dass die 200 Euro
diese
energiepreispauschale zügig bei den
Studierenden ankommen sollen darüber
sind sich nun wirklich ja alle einig das
war hier natürlich kein Diskussionspunkt
es wird nach Wegen gesucht wie man das
ganze bewerkstelligen kann wie das
möglichst schnell gehen soll die Ampel
hat bemängelt dass die Opposition ja
auch keine Vorschläge dazu vorlegen
würde und die Opposition hat bemängelt
dass die Ampel das eben nicht schnell
genug hinbekommen würde die Studenten
werden noch einen Moment darauf warten
müssen so viel scheint sicher denn das
Gesetzgebungsverfahren dazu zumindest
ist noch nicht
eingeleitet für die Rentner übrigens da
soll morgen die
Euro energiepreispauschale endgültig
beschlossen werden genauso wie auch und
das kommt dann zumindest einem Teil der
Studenten zugute ein zweiter
Heizkostenzuschuss in Höhe von 345 Euro
der morgen hier durch den Bundestag